you check this out right here now you're
not be intimidated by cooking Indian
food it's straightforward delicious and
more importantly this is so easy now for
the lamb kabobs first thing put a pan on
yeah get that nice and hot okay
we want that to get really nice and hot
so it seals the juices look about as
make them nicer station on one of these
ones with a dodgy handle that when
you're a bit like now where the handles
Biggs you won't be burning your hand now
do you like rages the rough start when
that man without that rust I've ever
liked man always blames his tools all
right right onion right here we go now
chop up the onion okay rice and the
chili now don't worry about chopping
them too funny cuz they're going in a
blender oh I'm now hit with the top take
the top of the chili open up the top of
the blender okay and put that come on
you can do it now you can animate now I
don't need to go to blend it okay right
here we go now in with onions here we go
now no just hold out Oh kids
I am not quite oh cool today about the
house in saw okay into the blender we've
where spices
lift up your spices oh yeah I've got
them laid out turmeric pink peppercorns
ground cloves and fennel seeds in okay
now
half half your mint half Niemann okay
half of it positive yeah mmm Arthur but
loud top ha just you to go for the
bottom half now blend okay that's how
that a little shade and push the button
first so your mate
that's it good now the idea okay he's
blending it's nice and funny I've got
these big lumps of red onion across
think about soft delicate and more
importantly the order disappear across
the means not identify them good well
done now have a little smell mmm
it's really strong come on this is
serious come on now into the mints yeah
good boy stay with me now please yes
this is a joke one a little bit a little
bit of salt and pepper okay and a secret
now your knees are the sort of blend
okay and we're gonna mix that up okay